we now finally will get to the story
that we teased a little bit yesterday I
wanted to make sure we had enough time
to get into it because it's it's
dominated the national discourse this of
course would be the that mother effort
isn't real lady from the airplane who
stood up
and and insisted that there was a mother
effort in the back of the airplane who
was not real and she said that the rest
of the passengers were free to stay on
the airplane and die with the unreal
person but she was going to leave the
airplane then she disappeared which I
felt was good for her and would have
been much better for her had she
remained Anonymous but the internet
figured out who she was somehow and now
this woman
is issuing an apology
Gomez probably better known as the crazy
plain lady which is completely warranted
as you know I
have been unwilling to speak on the
viral video but
this woman looks nothing like the woman
from the video
she looks nothing like her she has a
different hair color sure even her face
looks different I'm not saying it's a
different person or Invasion of the Body
Snatchers or something but
I'm saying it because had this woman
just gone about her daily life
no one would have recognized her
I don't know she she darkened her hair a
little bit I'm sure she went through a
tough time after that video went viral
but she's deciding for some reason to
make a big public spectacle of herself
again this time I think probably more
ill-advisedly than the first time
feel that it's time
first and foremost I want to
take full accountability for my actions
they were completely unacceptable
distressed or not I should have been I
should have been in control of my
emotions and no
that was not the case
my use of profanity was completely
unnecessary
and I want to apologize to everyone on
that plane especially those that had
children aboard
can't imagine going through that and
trying to explain to your kid what in
the world just happened
so she goes on and on this apology goes
on for something like two minutes
and I guess it's nice that she
is apologizing for using naughty
language around the kids even in our
culture where kids hear this all the
time that's that's the appropriate thing
to do but beyond that
why apologize
what happened
did did she have a psychotic episode
well then she has no reason to apologize
she she wasn't in control of herself and
I don't think through Vice or something
like that she just
went a little bit nuts for a moment is
it because she was
on some kind of substance or something I
don't know she doesn't mention that here
is it because
why apologize right now text nulls to
200 300 for most homeowners window
replacement is not something they've
done before for many it's not something
that they want to do rather it's
something they have to do if you've put
off replacing the windows in your home
because it's too expensive I've got
great news you can now get a free
in-home window consultation and a free
price quote from Renewal by Anderson
Renewal by Anderson's signature service
is committed to giving you the best
customer experience possible through the
perfect combination of the best people
in the industry a superior process and
an exclusive product right now renewable
by Anderson is offering a free in-home
or virtual consultation on top quality
affordable windows or patio doors for
zero dollars down zero payments and zero
interest for a year text nulls kwles to
200 300 for your free consultation to
save 375 off every window and 750 off
every door
these savings will not last long so be
sure to check it out by texting Knowles
Canada 200 300 that's Knolls to 200 300
texting and privacy policy in terms and
conditions posted at
textplan.us.us texting enrolls for
recurring automated text marketing
messages message and data rates may
apply reply stop to opt out go to window
appointmentnow.com for full offer
details right now go to
americanfinancing.net if you are like
most Americans you are struggling to
make ends meet and by the time you pay
the bills fill up your car and grocery
shop there's almost nothing left
everything is more expensive and most of
you are paying these bills with a credit
card Consumer Debt Rose over one
trillion dollars in the last year which
is the biggest increase in 20 years if
you're a homeowner there's a way out you
need to call my friends at American
financing they will put together a plan
to pay off that high interest credit
card debt and create meaningful savings
for you every month they're saving
people up to one thousand dollars a
month and closing in as fast 10 days
don't wait get yourself into a better
position call their salary-based
mortgage consultants today and see how
much you can save 25 years of experience
and 7 000 glowing Google reviews speak
volumes about their ability to save
homeowners money it costs nothing to get
started and if you start today you could
delay two mortgage payments giving you
greater savings up front call American
financing today at
866-721-30300 that's
866-721-3300 or visit
americanfinancing.net that's
americanfinancing.net this is a
phenomenon that has taken over the West
in in our social media age Jeremy has
has called out this weird phenomenon for
a long time Jeremy has called for the
end of public Apologies by private
persons public figures politicians
heads of Corporations maybe they can
make apology public apologies why This
Woman's not a public figure
if she wants to apologize she can
apologize to the airline she can write a
note to them or something have the
airline forward it out to the passengers
on the plane but what she doesn't owe me
an apology she doesn't owe you an
apology
why does everybody think that every
single little action every impulse has
to be public now probably comes from a
great place
Right comes from a good intention she's
trying to do the right thing so I'm
really not knocking her or criticizing
her but I'm giving a warning to
everybody else
you don't owe the public an apology for
your private actions most of the time
the only people she owes an apology to
or the airplane and maybe the people on
that plane she doesn't owe one to the
entire internet we don't need to make
our every aspect of our lives at every
level of community an international
phenomenon we don't
we don't need to broadcast every single
thing to the world
though I I suppose because of Technology
because of the growth of Technology such
that we can transport messages across
the world instantly and because of the
advance of liberal ideology which which
erodes communities the most basic
political community of the family and
local community and National borders and
everything because of the simultaneous
advance of those two phenomena now
we've lost all perspective of community
everything's Global and and every every
single message is a message to the world
intended to go viral and it does go
viral it's it is like a virus it is an
epidemic of of
publicity of we don't need to be so
transparent we don't need to we can
things can be private or relatively
private as we lose the sense of the
proper community
which comes through the abolition of the
family and borders and the eradication
of federalism decisions being made at a
more local level as we lose that the
political order gets entirely wonky such
that we've now got Americans as the
military spokesman in Ukraine such that
we've now got massive foreign influence
in the United States elections we've got
we've got uh now uh the criminalization
even of politics at the whims of a mob
not good stuff boy what a great clip
that was huh that was good right make
sure you ring the bell subscribe to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel we'll
see you next time